[Musique]
c'est sûr que quand on peut danser 8
secondes avec un taureau puis donner un
événement second filet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moore
c'est à l'âge de 7 ans que zachary
bourgeois monde sur son premier veau
puis des bouvillons des chevaux et enfin
les redoutables taureau petit à petit il
va développer sa passion et sa vocation
devenir co ba oui et danser avec les
taureaux sauvages
pour lui être encore bob n'est pas vivre
dans une autre époque
et peu importe ce que pensent les gens
de son choix de vie c'est sa passion
pour moi c'est complètement toute ma vie
puis mon but c'est d'être champion du
monde fixé par ci par là ya du monde qui
vont qui jugent du monde qui parle mais
ça fait partie de la game
[Musique]
quand on en mange plus on aimerait comme
ce challenge que je pourrais aussi dit
qu'être moi je pense que c'est les
instrus nouveau sport jetant de nouveau
jour
[Musique]
monter les taureaux sauvages des bêtes
de près de 2000 livres quand on n'en
pèse à peine 140 demande une
concentration de tous les instants
surtout que le cow boy ne connaît pas à
l'avancé la bête qu'il va monter à
chaque compétition
les taureaux sont tirés au sort une faut
donc s'adapter immédiatement aux styles
différents de chaque bête et surtout les
respecter sonder les peurs athlètes
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit ce rapport
77 génétique donc c'est trop là c'est
vraiment la meilleure
la mère productrice avec la main
reproducteurs pour donner les meurtres
au delà des autres faces les plus gros
pivot la fée rapidité la force l'agilité
du taureau pour nous donner le plus de
points
[Musique]
respect si c'est très important que ça
ces animaux là on prêt pour pratiquer
notre pompier face qu'on aime fait que
c'est sûr que quand on peut danser un
bon feeling joie après ses études
secondaires
zachary va s'exiler dans l'ouest
canadien pour parfaire son métier est
entré dans le très prestigieux circuit
professionnel américain
à 17 ans il est déjà un phénomène au
canada car cela fait deux ans qu'il a
quitté les rangs juniors pour ceux des
seniors et cela grâce à des
entraînements rigoureux où chaque détail
est primordial son sport est aussi celui
de l'humilité on est souvent à l'échec
comme je dis souvent les professionnels
le taps encore monde dont 50% de leur
toro fait que ça nous arrive souvent de
dévoiler cheikh se relever puis toujours
continuer à avancer
réfléchissez sur le poteau sur le centre
est attaché petit réfléchi et une
crainte et oublie ce
pour le jeune cowboy de saint tite monte
des taureaux sauvages c'est comme une
chorégraphie danse dangereuse certes
mais tellement intense en émotions
conscients des dangers de son sport à
gap il en perd pas pour autant son sens
de l'humour
[Applaudissements]
ouais
j'appris des banques peuvent s'appuyer
dessus puis c'est pas un co je vais
juste à deux essais ici robert frosi
radio canada saint tite
[Musique]